кради був тебе ердоган такс канду йти
проти увальни до
він і поважає cb прямий стиму референдуму
тисячі людей у ​​стамбулі і вийшла на буду
this ви богом у пророк він гула сил я
протестую цей м'яз я сказав вони не
не президентській системі не могло і
не буду прям агата
1000 виведення кулі база я викладу в інших
вожатому дією і конверти б штанги
і тебе заяву сталь на кораблях
ми просто диктатури вибір що комісія
за успіхами ви вирішила примати страву тіні
б за 5 іншого штампу я є позиції ти
можеш виробництв дозування двох з
половиною мільйонів докладних вул та сил
врятувати рогачі такий же розкритий у кого
тільки проходів референдум особливо вкрай
обожненню важливість про поклич проводити
передвиборну кампанію я хочу вибір це
просто правил і б свій великий компанії
так я вже на глушу молодці bull він і
рівно підлогу гри не було паритетності в
умовах проведення агітації
так малими сцени ви правда не
оподаткування фундаментальних свобод людей
на президент ердоган витка на всі зака
до них який продовживши нападати вона за
hide pe година мітингу в анкарі
готелі землі ми не хочемо у не бачу тоні
тут і ваші політичному ти вова найду
поведи модему своїм шляхом скажіть моєму
cup ілюху
вся україна побачила на білчат йому
критичні вибори та яких nikon і була
адже вона вже дні через сильні краї за
за переднім і результатом і вище 50 та 1
500 до вибірки 53 вміло плани у ердогана
на референдумі
височіють над ще половиною ви будете
проголосувала проти президент схожа на
травня на світ uruha тис на премку
тримери не україни на курорті чан і
продовжу sinatra my city
назви чайний став українці їм ідею якова
злих кивнув у руку тисячі політичних
опонентів був і за рижкова немає тепер
супротивників ердогану бояться любиш їх
репресій та скачування околиці до
диктатури
[оплески]